hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to and
welcome to another edition of old versus
new
this is where I take something old and
nostalgic and compare it to a recent
remake with that so let's take a look at
what are the Rings
becoming the Holy Bible of geekdom Lord
of the Rings by JRR tolkien has
revolutionized the style of fantasy and
given a whole new respect to the genre
many of us know about the Peter Jackson
movies based on the books that came out
between 2001 2003 but there was another
version that came out in the 70s that a
lot of people don't know about this was
rubbish geese Lord
well consider both the critical and
box-office disappointment bash be slower
rings offered a very different take on
the classic story and has since then
either been loved by fans or - tested by
them but isn't anything compared to the
big-budget extravaganza of the Jackson
movies now technically speaking this is
all opinion based but I have an online
show which automatically means that my
opinion is better than yours nananana so
let's take a look at Ralph's bash G and
Peter Jackson's
now see how the ralph bakshi film ends
at the exact same point that the Pierre
Jackson film the two towers ends I
decided to include the two towers in
this comparison as was the Fellowship of
the Ring
but that said let's take a look at our
main character Frodo Baggins
one of the things I love about the
Jackson lore the Rings movies is the
casting everybody in these movies looks
the part and I heard Elijah Wood was
going to play Frodo I thought it was the
best casting since Keanu Reeves played
that mentally retarded boy and Bill &
Ted's Excellent Adventure I am an
adventure turned out to be quite
different he was kind innocent and
extremely bold but maybe a little too
vulnerable in the basket version photo
is just as wide-eyed and curious but he
does fight back and can also stand up
for himself not true they most save Sam
from Gollum but the Basking one seems to
be a little tougher and in control I
would put you down on command you to
leap off a cliff or into a fire and you
would do its makeup like here's what the
Black Riders trying to attack fertile
actually gets out his sword and does try
to fight in the Jackson one he just
drops it
if you could kindly stab yourself with
that I'd be most thankful or how about
another encounter with the Black Riders
even though he's sick and can barely
stay awake he actually manages to make
his way past the river and even
intimidate though sorry sorry
by all the Shire you shall have neither
the ring nor made the Jackson one just
sort of passes out and let someone else
carry him off
by the way how does that work if the
sword wound works its way to his heart
he becomes one of the black writers
would I have you would have become like
them one of the Ring wraiths wouldn't
that be a little um awkward I mean I
don't think they look as a timid ad if a
little guy in a cloak is running around
yeah maybe they just give him a desk job
I do eight Mondays even though I love
Elijah Wood is Frodo the basking one
just seemed a little stronger as well as
closer to the book
no offense would the point goes to Becky
what do you know about it
nothing
but what about the supporting cast the
little people who make it possible for
the other little people there's a lot to
get through so let's take a gander
now this one's really hard because the
rest of the cast is sort of hit and miss
Sam in the Jackson film for example as a
tough royal friend who will stick with
mr. Frodo through thick and thin don't
you leave him Samwise Gamgee
can I don't mean to while Sam and the
Baskerville is not I mean good god what
did they do to you Sam I really don't
know what went wrong with this character
but they fucked up when mr. Brogan mr.
Frodo he's gone he's sick and he needs a
rest help a dragon and I want my bottle
someone give me my bottle shot which is
funny because merry and pippin are at
the opposite ends of the spectrum as
well in the jackson film they're a
little overplay making them a tad too
goofy but still all around my thing that
works good let's get another one at
where the bashed evil they're actually
under played seeming a little bit more
like real-life people but to be honest
not leaving much of an impression you
cannot trust us to let you face trouble
alone and go up without a word we're
your friends Frodo well thank you Pippin
I'm Mary whatever you're all short
gandalf is good both versions breeding
this strong mythical element while also
mixing in the side effects of his age
this last journey must be for others to
make ah and who are they to be that is
what they're trying to decide here my
problem is in the bash B film he's a
little too over-the-top I compare these
two scenes where he yells in heaven fool
of a threw yourself in next time and rid
us of your stupidity fool of a duck so
yourself in next time fool what what oh
oh oh but one of the biggest differences
is Aragorn which is totally blown away
by the bash B film now granted I'm not
quite sure why it looks like a Native
American that certainly wasn't the
sign of the book but the character is
still a million times better
why well being voiced by John heard one
of the greatest actors of all time
certainly helps my name is Aragorn son
of Arathorn but on top of that the idea
behind ever going to safety was both a
ranger and a king with the Jackson
version you certainly buy the Ranger
part but I never really saw anything
kingly in it decide the Ranger become
who you were born to be
by killing things and slaughtering
evildoers just do a very kingly the best
people ones seem to pull off both he
could be a badass but he could also be
very smooth and diplomatic Lothlorien
has a place of healing there is no evil
in it and unless a man brings evil bear
with him on top of that he could also be
very intimidating because if I wanted
the ring for myself I could have it now
please don't kill me the Jackson will
never seem to have that confidence or
inner strength that the other one had
and the only King we think ever did was
make a motivational speech I see in your
eyes the same fear that would take the
heart of me okay may come when the
courage of men fails but it is not this
day this day we fight I mean who the
hell could possibly get a role of
leadership by having no political
background and just making a bunch of
pretty speech okay fine but you gotta
give them credit they both have totally
different ways of dealing with their
problems for example when a horrible
threat comes across King Aragorn he
fails them out with billions of dollars
and hopes they know how to spend it
wisely
but gene for aragorn's weaknesses though
Jackson Phil makes up for it with the
addition of Gollum which has done much
better at Jackson's version again the
baby one isn't bad they certainly have
the addiction down in the hinting
towards madness oh yeah yes it lays nice
obit but the Jackson one really took the
character to a whole new level
he was devious but sympathetic when bad
things happened to him you've got
genuinely sorry like to us always
plus they really play around the split
personality bit
I love come back come back I'll be right
back coca-cola yeah we want original
classic calories we're trying to miss
right no relax
right sweetie just suck you suck there's
of course a ton of other characters but
they're all kind of on the same level
they're good but not great each having
their strengths and weaknesses
tough cold I'm gonna go with the Jackson
one mostly because they have more time
in two movies to flesh their characters
out and that's a huge advantage sorry
Gandalf we still love you what
euros don't mean crap unless you have
some good villains to go up against and
these movies had plenty
again from a casting point of view you
could have got a better pick than
Christopher Lee for sorrows he look the
part acted the part but most of all he
sounded the part sarang's forces are
already moving the nine have left Mina's
Morgul God there is that voice cool
it did not seriously take there's an
object of contend with a will of soda I
think it's another one of those voices
you don't want reading bedtime stories
to your kids though once upon a time
there were three bears three innocent
sweet Oh suspecting bears
I wonder the bass you film is okay but
you don't see much about where is the
ring Gandalf why'd you rather see the
Dark Lord have it oh no please don't
flash me something I never understood in
the Banshee film though is for some
reason they stopped pronouncing the s
and simply calm our maps why is the S
suddenly a bad word only because our
bond is kind it should have been his
friend our man how long since Harriman a
double-barrel an auto man it is
pronounced Saruman dance isn't silent
also how come Gandalf can never figure
out the sorrow mom's gonna be a bad guy
I mean do these look like the homes of
any decent people you know your love of
the halflings leaf has clearly slowed
your mind oh stop hushing my buzz flick
writers are all hard to decide between
two I mean the Jacksonville odds were
cool especially how you never see their
faces
but the baggy ones were also pretty
intimidating ranging from fragile creepy
folk to tough soldiers of darkness
almost as if their power feared in and
out at times so again they do go a bit
over the top end moments give the Tyler
though also the Jackson version I
thought the way they looked we put the
ring on was a little goofy if I didn't
ever like the way things look we put the
ring on it's like a third grader went
nuts with the smudge to our Photoshop in
the basket fell they don't really change
but you can tell you've entered a
different world
everything's slower the color changes
it's almost like a different state of
being but for me the big deciding point
is the lord of darkness itself Sauron
and believe it or not I actually like
the Basti one better
simply because you never see him the
most we get is a guy in a viking hat
which isn't very intimidating but
everything else is kept a mystery you
never see him but you can always feel
his presence simply by the way people
talk about him under the power of Sauron
the Dark Lord of Mordor look at the
scene with the eye in the fountain you
came to tell that it is an eye but the
fear that fills everybody is still
present do not touch the water he's
looking for you
the door is closed
if your quest fails then nothing can
stand against him and we are defenseless
now let's look at the Jacksonville it's
just too overblown the item looks more
like a lizard side which indicates on is
more of a monster than he is a man even
his costume seems over-the-top
there's just nothing subtle about it
when I think of the Lord of Darkness I
think of something sneaky conniving and
quiet not loud bombastic and
in-your-face
let me saw Sauron as a plotter someone
who's waiting to strike in the shadows
where this guy seems like the Hulk's
metal pincushion
Oh
sword mean Sauron have explosive
diarrhea
Sarang go boom so like I said before
tough call but seeing how less is
usually more I have to go into
Baskerville because let's face it no one
can bring the dread and feelings of doom
than the guy who directed cool world huh
point goes to Becky Oh
well that's all fine and good but how
can they beat the shit out of each other
here's the best actions
now both these stones are unique and how
they do their actions
Jackson's movies are a little bit more
acrobatic and inventive where Bosch
needs is a little bit more gritty and
bloody it's interesting to how the
Jackson films do the Battle of Helm's
Deep in all blue and the Bosch key film
does the battle and on red I don't even
know why it turns all red just looks
really cool
in another flip-flop where the baski
felt have little build up but a lot of
payoff the Jackson film has a lot of
build up but little payoff what do I
mean by this well in the batch
conversion there's a real feeling of
suspense in tension I mean when someone
gets dead you really felt like you're
getting stabbed in the Jackson one they
tempt death just a few too many times I
mean they literally jump into the middle
of an army of Orcs not once not twice
but three times and not once do they
ever get a scratch on them because I
shouldn't defend the bench you film too
much though
I mean look when they fire the arrows
the numb nuts don't even move I'm far
too proud to be searching for color I
like this place to be good drunk here
good right and we won't be taking the
listed advantage of magic for an event
now of course the return to King is some
of the best action scenes ever but since
- he never made it that far
I really don't count it but still the
action in the Jackson films really are
better they're more flashy more creative
and more energized
I would like to seen a little bit more
grisly and realistic but then again it
is a fancy so I guess anything goes
point goes to Jason then you know
nothing
so once again it comes down to story
which one had a better plot the better
painting and the better delivery let's
take story front away
it is interesting how both Vashti and
Jackson enter films at the exact same
point they when the Battle of Helm's
Deep and Gollum lead Sam and Frodo does
she lobe even though when the ball comes
deep is in the middle and they already
met up wish you look great
she my pilk mm-hmm and again the
Jacksonville has the advantage that has
two films to explain the story and where
- he only has one because of this the
bash key film suffers characters can't
be fleshed out like they should and some
characters just disappear altogether our
wind ever makes an appearance in a one I
don't even think ever gets a line she
just stands there
my sister daughter ailing my only loyal
kin since her brother has disobeyed my
commands unfortunately she's a mute but
the Jackson Felmy time seems a bit
rushed
- like I never did enjoy the editing of
the first film it seemed way too
fragmented not the Shires been invited
Roberta
he's up to something alright then keep
your secrets I like talking in sentences
without any pauses don't you yes I do I
like it a lot indeed huh
antibodies credit for all the scenes he
had to cut the scenes it does keep in
are often very quiet and usually allow
for a lot of atmosphere which I think in
a lot of ways is closer to the books
take for example when Gimli finds out
two wars in the mines of Moria have all
been destroyed here's the Jackson
version
Oh Eli's body Oh Suze I feared oh oh now
here's the master version yesterday
Balin Lord of Moria fell an orc shot him
from behind a stone he doesn't scream he
doesn't yell he just slowly walks away
to be by himself it's a lot more
powerful but to be fair Jackson's film
has a lot of powerful scenes too many of
which were not even focused on that much
in the book like our ones debate about
choosing immortal life it's really
looked into and analyzed you will linger
on and darkness and in doubt there's
even a few subtle scenes as well like in
the bashed you film Frodo makes a big
speech about how they probably never get
back I reckon we got enough left to
seize to this Mount Doom after that you
I dunno Oh sad friend of friends after
that if the ring goes into the fire and
we're at hand after that dear Sam just
to get there just to get there yet in
the Jackson film is literally just sewed
off in a walk you go ahead and eat them
I've rationed it there should be enough
for what the journey home that look at
Lars used to say everything and as the
films went on they did get progressively
better it better taking their time with
the story and not feeling as rushed as
before so while I have to admit it's not
really a close call there are a lot of
elements in the Banshee film that are
not only subtle but really work well
it's a lot of over-the-top moments sure
and some scenes don't really make sense
but what they do get right they get
really right so even though this is
probably a surprise to no one the film
that really is better is the Peter
Jackson version the superior
so there you go Peter Jackson vs. Ralph
Becky I do feel bad I'm not able to
compare return the King to anything oh
wait a minute the rack and bass version
that's right they did return the King
well I'll just compare those two that
I'm the Nostalgia Critic I remember it
so you don't have to
you